I talk out against drugs and psychiatric
abuses of electric shocking people of
drugging children with them not knowing
the effects of these drugs do you know
what Adderall is do you know Ritalin do
you know now that Ritalin is a street
drug the difference is
your question Matt I'm asking a question
I understand there's abuse of all of
these things now you see here's the
problem you don't know the history of
Psychiatry I do you're not getting to
the reason why there is no such thing as
a chemical imbalance I'm saying that
drugs aren't the answer that these these
drugs are very dangerous they're
mind-altering
antipsychotic drugs and there are ways
of doing it without that so that we
don't end up in A Brave New World okay
I'm not testifying to every single thing
that Tom Cruise said there like is there
no such thing as a chemical imbalance
like I'm not sure about that we are
grewing around with the chemicals in our
brain and then we wonder why we now have
a generation of people that don't know
what their what gender they